hi it's time to play some roller coaster
Kim three also I might just use that as
my new intro but it still sucks but my
own intro also sucks and it's risotto
why do they even exist but anyway I
decided to do a roller coaster tycoon 3
let's play tutorial again instead of
silver city because I don't have any
videos of that anymore for one reason
that I'm going to talk about and it's
the same reason that I've also been
uploading like no scope and and that one
ronica sent even a ski lift like why did
I upload a ski lift well here's the
reason so this week I was kind of sick
so I couldn't record anything because
you wouldn't even want to hear my voice
back then and plus I didn't even want to
get out of bed so really that was not
very great but I still had to upload
videos of course so I had that I had
that skill left still laying around and
I figured that I would have met I should
make a video of it simply because I make
that cuz I'm seen reset for that and I
didn't want to make a video for it but I
couldn't feature it in the video of the
roller coaster because the rules of the
contest stated that you can have any
tracks right outside the boundaries of
the roller coaster so there you go
there's another video for a cable car so
that's also a new thing I've never seen
a cable car POV in roller coaster tycoon
3 so that's actually pretty cool yeah
that's actually I like that that's
actually a great idea I almost just
figured that I would just change the
things that I do in roller coaster
tycoon 3 it's like not even silver at
the coaster builder anymore it's silver
at that guy who those cable cars and ski
lifts but know that that wouldn't be too
much of a success so I'm not going to
not going to do that don't worry I'm
still going to make roller coaster
videos but I did feel like the let's
play is something that I haven't done in
a while so decided to just record this
and then once i get school out of the
way and once i actually get some time
when i can record a things again I feel
like it i'm just going to record in a
bog and then just upload loads of things
so that's how that will works another
life update OBS people have been asking
me whether i use OBS to record my videos
and yes i do most of the times these
days simply because i used to use fraps
but
it's fraps creates uncompressed avi
files I don't think that makes sense i
think that AVI finals are always
uncompressed that's why the shitty and
annoying but yeah the problem with that
is that every single file of fraps even
if it would be just three minutes it
would be a couple of gigs of space
basically on my hard drive and I have a
shitty laptop and recording loads of
Let's Plays of time lapses of hours of
in-game time on AVI files uncompressed
using fraps it's not something that your
computer is going to like so what I had
to do was record an episode and then
edit it and render it and right away
remove all of the fraps files and then
start recording something else but this
meant that i couldn't bulk record and
this also meant that most of the times i
couldn't require eyes and what i was
doing in rolla co second three and i had
to wait for sony vegas to actually
finish rendering but that would take
five hours so that wasn't a great
situation so now I use OBS instead but
the quality is somewhat lower it's not
too bad I think I don't know if did I
just breathe into my mic if yes then I
should probably move it here we go but
basically what was I talking about okay
let's see yeah okay so ovs files were
not as high-quality as for EPS files but
I did change something in the settings
and edit more bytes for their the thingy
I don't even know how to explain it
really I sucker comes at computer stuff
but i just changed settings and then it
magically kind of fixed itself so that
was great but yeah i'm using OBS and for
now it seems to be working fine there's
only one problem it does record your
screen instead of roller coaster second
three so i play in windowed mode now
which is handy with some things because
now i can easily go to skype and other
things while I'm recording and just cut
it out if you have the game in full
screen mode and you have a terrible
laptop like I do it takes hours to
actually close the game so that's not
very handy but the only problem that I
do have with that is that i always
forget about things so for this video i
was in a skype call and I forgot that I
was in a skype call so at the little
skype finger
still in the upper right corner so
that's also why I pended in a weird way
because I didn't want that skyping and
now I figured it's pretty cool because
you do also miss the blue boy at the top
of the roller coaster tycoon 3 screen as
well don't know if that's a good thing
or a bad thing but I just decided to go
with it now for a quick update on what
I'm actually doing right now is I looked
at the station I was like me actually no
that's not what happened first of all I
tried building a station for that wing
rider and I recorded it and then halfway
through building that station I felt
like it was an absolute turd it was
absolutely ridiculously bad so I was
like okay throw this away so that was
now a waste of my time I had to throw
that fight file away and I recorded that
but that didn't make much sense so I was
like okay I'm not going to cut out
anything but this is so terrible I can't
even I can't even that I can't even like
literally I can't even so decided to
throw that away and just work on this
because this station looks kind of may
so I felt like maybe if i add ridiculous
buildings next to it it would be
somewhat better so that's what I'm going
for right now and of course I'm adding a
little sour because towers are always
awesome and I'm addicted to those things
who isn't honestly and I tried handing
those weird things don't know why I did
that and of course I removed them in the
end because that was kind of ridiculous
but there was also something else I
wanted to talk about and that was the
fact that I'm actually talking over the
time-lapse right now instead of actually
adding music because when I asked like
you guys about whether you prefer
timelapses or I would prefer time-lapses
with music or time lapse with commentary
i actually got some mixed reactions and
i kind of expected to be honest that
most people would actually like it with
commentary more but to be fair you did
bring some good arguments like the fact
that some people watch my videos without
actually turning on the sound honestly I
would probably do that myself too and
then you do feel like you're missing out
in some commentary and then there's also
the fact that some people like to music
I don't know how because I absolutely
hate that music but yeah i put music
my own videos that I don't even like
yeah that's me shut up so yeah now I
felt like I'm just going to record this
with commentary because this is the
first time in a week I've actually been
able to do some commentary so I want to
get this down okay so that also I want
to kind of work on my comment I don't
know if I really want to work on my
commentary doing what to it yeah
probably i do because we were talking
about that's cool yeah that was that was
really funny like we were in like
economics class what's so it's sort of
economics but it's a special type I
don't even know what to call it in
English as is [ __ ] amino I don't even
know what it is but basically we were
talking about this and youtube
partnership and silver at and all that
and I was like oh god here we go so we
had a conversation about that and
teacher came in I was like oh [ __ ] was
screwed and the teacher just joined the
conversation it was like what are you
doing so we didn't do anything that
class we just talked about my youtube
channel and all that but yeah that's
that's when I taught them and also
realized like for once after all that my
channel is probably not about me it's
not about the commentary not per se not
like you watch PewDiePie for the
commentary or for the for the person who
felix is of course but it's more about
what I build in roller coaster second
three and that's also the way that I
feel about it so really I don't think
Palminteri is too much of an important
thing but I should probably kind of work
on it and working on that of course does
include gothic getting an actual good
microphone and getting a good pc in
general but also probably like I know
the other classes on how to make youtube
videos that probably are like honestly
their problem in some stupid people felt
like that's a good market let's invest
in that I let's earn loads of money off
of stupid teenagers who want to become
rich and famous off of youtube yeah
sounds cool but not something for me
really I feel like I don't even want to
move into YouTube too much because I
feel like I'm really in the wall coach
tycoon 3 community and it's it's this
little I think and yeah and seven once
call it the make-believe world of roller
coaster code three and
that's not success and that's exactly
how I feel about it it's just a nice
small community and I feel like I don't
want to trade is that nice small
community for the big and money earning
community where I could possibly get
famous on YouTube but where it wouldn't
just feel the same that's how I feel
about that but yeah back to rolla co
second three well the game what I'm
building right now is I feel like mmm I
need some kind of big building with the
break section really I just went for
this building without even thinking
about anything that's how I do things
sometimes I don't know why I do that or
how that even happens but I was in a
skype call I was kind of sick I was just
building this this thing and i was like
huh let's just go with the flow let's
just go with whatever my brains come up
with on the spot and decided to build
that and honestly it looks a bit weird
but it's also unique in a sense and i
think honestly if I would say anything
about roller coaster tycoon 3 or
creative things in general it's probably
that it's better to make something
that's really unique that's kind of bad
they're making something that's good but
it's been done before dozens of times so
really I wouldn't want to do the same
thing over and over again even if it
looks good I would rather just
experiment with things and even if I get
things that look weird terrible or just
out of place in general but they're
unique then I probably be happy with it
honestly and through trying new things
you can always find some new things that
are actually somewhat more unique of
course you do need to get some
experience and some good feel as to how
that new style kind of works and but the
only thing that I have with this is that
the shape and the general concept of
this because who built who builds a
building with arcs over it over a break
section before the station like I
haven't even seen that before really
especially not on this height like it's
somewhat of a common thing to add
buildings to break state to break
stations what to break section but but
not really on this height not this high
really it kind of seems weird but then
again it's kind of cool I guess and
loads of colors again because
colors are awesome especially when it
comes to alpine buildings you should
always have all kinds of colors and
those things but yeah when it comes to
this Pike there's also something that I
I kind of want to say I don't know if
I've set this before but I'm kind of
getting tired of this Pike and this
happens with anybody with the roller
coaster 3 and now the way that most
people solve this of course is abandon
the project to move on and that's why
99% of all the projects on ICT three
have been abandoned and just Lee left on
shy guys world or healthy all the tire
forms to just die and rot for all
eternity and that's one thing that my
let's play kind of saves me from because
I have to work on this bike I have to
finish this let's play I have to finish
this in order to move on to something
else and that's kind of I feel like that
I feel like I need to do that but then
again it's it's it's a good thing
because it kind of forces me to actually
finish something and not leave all my
projects unfinished but then again it
does feel more like a toy than a game
sometimes and that's why I decide to
build coasters like my upcoming crackage
Buster which is absolutely ridiculous
and today this morning I had the idea to
make a coaster called superfast
jellyfish it's going to be amazing if I
actually make it like definitely i've
been thinking about nothing fitting for
years but it just suddenly popped into
my mind this morning so might work on
that and then there's the fact that i'm
not going to reveal that ok let's
there's going to be a collaboration on a
project that's been going on for years
because collaborations is also something
that I want to talk about but i'll talk
about that in a minute but there's been
a collaboration that's been going on for
years it's it was kind of a
collaboration between two people but one
worked more on it than the other but in
the end they both abandon it and then
decided to give it to me and it's been a
plan like that for a very long time but
it never really happened but it seems
like it's going to happen now so that's
going to be pretty cool well basically
ok so when it comes to collapse and this
is something that i don't like when it
comes to like having this following on
youtube is that so many people request
me to do collabs and I wish that I could
actually
except all of those requests and I could
actually say yeah let's make roller
coasters together because that's that's
awesome and it's really cool that people
ask me for that but the only problem
that I have with this is that so many
people ask me and I've so little time
that I can't accept all of them but then
again I don't want to just like accept
random collapse for from random people i
don't know and not accept random caller
collapse from other people for the same
reason which just seems unfair to me so
I've decided to incline well no decline
wit well all of the collab requests that
I get except for if I request someone
else or collapse to have been going on
for years already so yeah that's about
the entire colon thing but anyway this
is pretty much the end of the video so
thank you guys so much for watching and
see you on the next one so till then